I know gave me thrones' over it which
I'm incredibly sad about so I figure
good game of Thrones meme is a good way
to start my name is Luther Hill I'm a
data scientist I work for the Army's the
Medical Department I work in the
operations department so I do a lot of
and a lot of analysis on marketing spend
so next time you hear about somebody
spending a bunch of money on marketing
and hiring people and firing people and
building stuff it's not my fault
somebody in Chicago who just fired them
really it was like 36 million dollars a
month of waste yeah
but moving on from there what we're
trying to do is build a data works a lot
of my job involves and I'm sure like a
lot of data scientist involves a lot of
repeatable processes I usually do the
same report same kind of analysis use
the same data on my models fairly
consistently so I try to automate a lot
of like as much as I can
initially the way I did that was the
good old fashioned cron job everybody
loves a good cron job I love a good cron
job it's the best thing ever
my girlfriend on the other hand did not
like my cron job because I set up a
small raspberry pie server in the house
that I was just kind of using to offload
a lot of random data and just bunch of
random stuff so one day I wanted to
scrape some Twitter data and then I set
up a cron job I've like most good data
scientists ever completely forgot about
the cron job it ran for days and weeks
on end at the end of it I try to log on
to do something some minor nonsense and
then it just wouldn't work and I'm like
you know what's going on what's
happening it's got to be raspberry pie
this thing you know horrible is it's
worthless
so I log on there and sure enough my
sixth gigabyte memory stick was
completely full of tweets that's a lot
of you can imagine that's a lot of
tweets I mean it that's a lot of tweets
but that's for sure the power
of a cron job so the basic agenda isn't
uh called about myself talk about data
science as I see it talk about the
problem statement do a little bit of
hands-on not anything super live but
we'll kind of look at the data and then
talk about the conclusion so like we
talked about me that's me right there my
major interest really is in more health
care health care equity health care
stuff this is how I got started for
patchy airflow actually because once
again I was trying to automate another
web scraping process for something else
that I'm doing and then I realized that
the cron job was not going to work this
time it was definitely not gonna work I
needed something more repeatable I
needed something that I could start
stopped that I could sort of add some
actual workload at and also really set
up a process so it got me started
looking at patchy air for when I decide
to do this presentation about it I'm
also really passionate about diversity
inclusion in tech so it's always great
when I come to conferences like this and
I see a lot of people being represented
from different backgrounds I really love
that so it's really amazing
data science truths as I see them a lot
of people have this miss representation
of what data science is I think a lot of
data science the easy statistic is 80%
of what I do is really data engineering
I was having a great conversation with
somebody in the back about that very
thing where it's most of the models
unless you're doing something maybe at
Google Way more Facebook where
everything is custom a lot of what
you're doing is just really about
engineering it's really about how do I
move data from point A to point B how do
I connect to this data base
how do I clean my data and then how do I
at the end produce a result you know
whatever that might be be a you know I
like to think it's a fancy new model
that it's gonna change the world
sometimes it's just an interesting
visualization of our marketing spend
it's a ninja life interesting
visualization of our operations of
patient sentiment what they think about
us because all the doctors like to know
what is my patient think about me how do
they you know
leaving me good reviews bad reviews and
it's kind of hard to discern that when
you have you have anything from a
Facebook page you have a website with
comments you have a Twitter you have
random notes in a bucket somewhere so
you try to figure out how can I put all
those things together and then how can I
get them to do something so humans are
more important than the data upfront I
really believe that because at the end
of the day the data can't make a
decision only a human being can actually
make a decision and take action to do
something with it your data is only good
as your storytelling the data itself is
not going to convince anybody the model
is not going to convince anybody your
fancy data pipeline is not going to
convince anybody what's really gonna
convince somebody is solving a problem
and telling a story with the data your
data is biased and so are you we hear
about it all the time as far as data
bias I think Google had a big thing
recently where they paid a bunch of
people to go out to Atlanta and other
heavily african-american cities to get
more pictures of African Americans so
that they're machine learning algorithm
wouldn't be so biased against African
Americans and people of color which I
didn't know was a thing I know I'm like
okay sounds good but that just goes to
show you the Machine only really knows
what you tell it it's it's biased if you
feed it a bunch of data with one
particular thing that's what it's gonna
solve for so you have to understand that
and you have to build your pipeline to
once again reflect some diversity not
only in images but in numbers and data
sources in different things like that it
gives you a more complete picture so a
basic problem statement is I went to
Pike on this year I was my first time
attending really great for anybody who
hasn't gone but the basic thing we're
gonna try to solve is we're a marketing
firm or and we just want to find out
what people think what people on Twitter
specifically think about PyCon right we
want to mine the tweets and and figure
out what are they
they like it they not like it or even if
we come here right we want to look at
the comments and say that they liked it
they did not like it what was
interesting what was not what was the
engagement so we do that first by
admitting the truth which is your data
is dirty it
it's absolutely filthy if you take a
look at it oh it really is if you take a
look at it there's I mean there's
anything from missing values which you
have to account for
there's incorrect values which you have
to account for I mean you know how it is
with users they kind of just do their
own thing you ask them for a number they
put in a string you ask them for a
picture they put in a bunch of text you
ask you know it's just what it is the
other thing too if it's in your database
it's already good right it made it to
the database
it must be golden it like it is the
truth
no so we have to understand that and we
have to engineer around those different
things so part of the presentation we're
going to talk about data engineering
just as a general process like anything
else there has to be a process airflow
is just a tool it doesn't solve the
underlying problem which is how do we
build an effective data pipeline how do
we take data from point A to point B
what air flow does it makes it
repeatable it makes it trackable it
makes it consistent but it doesn't
actually solve the bigger pipeline issue
there so what we have to look at is one
that the engineer solution we have to
think about what databases are we
connecting to Apache air flow is open
source so it has a lot of really great
connectors I can connect to [ __ ] SQL
AWS as your all the different cloud
platforms so there's a lot of different
connectors in there I actually built my
connector around the twe P API to
connect to using my own credentials to
connect to Twitter bit Twitter's API
back-end and then get tweets out of
there and for anybody who was following
politics which I don't know if anybody
is Twitter's very big thing right now
and the current status is that you can
get
third back to 30 days of user data so I
could go in and mine the last 30 days on
a rotating basis of what people were
saying about any given topic prior to
2016 it used to be as far back as you
wanted so I I don't know if anybody knew
what happened in 2016 why they might
have changed Twitter and don't want you
to just open wide access anymore but
it's not like that anymore
so first what do you think about
connecting to the database then the next
thing is the preparation of the data
like we talked about the data is dirty
right how many of us in here have opened
up a database and what should be a null
is a string you know what should be a
string is a number what should be a user
ID is an emoji
you know I because that's it was an
interesting point his presentation
together and I was um I was just like on
the terminal doing some stuff and for
some reason Apple allows you to do to
add emojis so there's like I wrote some
code in vs code where I could actually
print out an emoji like the actual
unicorn emoji something I'm and now I
thought to myself like I wonder if I
could put that in a database
you know like that'd be kind of cool to
like figure out a way to get that emoji
in a database and really mess with the
administrator there so a good data
pipeline is reproducible which is why
data data pipeline as code much like you
know you have devops or infrastructure
is cold it's very very powerful because
otherwise what happens in the data
science world is that it tends to be a
very one of process it tends to be me
kind of ad hoc or making something very
custom for that one particular use case
and then I forget about it and then six
gigs later you know we're trying to
restart my Raspberry Pi so by making it
code we can have version control over it
right so now our data pipeline version
one could be doing one particular thing
but then through iteration realize okay
this is in that good
let's do version two so now we have data
pipeline version two and why that's
important for a lot of businesses
especially what I do which is working
for the government very heavy regulated
very security focused and when that
young man was talking about NIST I like
100% understood it because NIST is the
document documents that I live in die by
like we're all about NIST because it's
all about federal government so that I
have to be able to show how I did things
and airflow allows me to do that because
I can go back to the code and say this
was version 1 of my code execute it and
have a reproducible result versus I kind
of custom make my own code and then it
ends up you know version 1 is not the
same as version 2 I don't know where
version 2 is I forgot about it so it
just makes it a little bit easier and
analytics is really what a lot of the
data that's the answer that you're
trying to get and Apache airflow also
helps with that as well because you can
as part of your workflow kick out CSV
files text files you can kick out
visualizations you can store it to an s3
bucket so literally you could have your
entire pipeline from scraping Twitter to
cleaning that data taking on any crazy
mo G's and then running an analysis on
it and storing that analysis in a CSV
file or an s3 bucket completely
automated end to end and also version
controlled so if you wanted to go later
on and change it you could totally do
that
some basic air flow concepts so we have
tasks tasks instance dag and dag run a
task is really is a unit of work so
there's a particular thing that you're
asking air flow to do you could run
multiple tasks at the same time you
could have multiple task instances but
your that's what I think about it it's
like you're asking the computer to just
one particular thing I
a dag and I'm probably gonna mess up
this the way I say this directed a
cyclical graph directed a cyclical graph
is a fancy way of saying that that the
graph has order it has a sequence so
Apache airflow will always do things in
the sequence that you set through the
code so if you want to go to the Twitter
API first then you want to hit up
instagrams
API which is also a very rich source of
data and then combine both of those
things into one database or one data
table and then export it to a CSV file
you could do that now you have two very
different social media platforms two
very different social media information
sources put together one one analysis
that I ran that I found very interesting
was a lot of businesses tend to have
similar names or handles across
different social media platforms but
they tend to put out very dissimilar
messages across those platforms meaning
that on Twitter you might you know be
very a great example was the NBA I love
basketball that's what I follow
so anybody heard about the NBA
controversy of China right you heard
about that where on the English media
they put out a very kind of muted you
know you know we're not supportive of it
we're kind of like want to stay out of
it message but on the Chinese media they
put out this very bad bad Houston
Rockets type message where with you
people of China we you know we don't
think it's the right thing that they did
it had to come back and clean it up when
somebody showed that hey there's two
very different messages so it's a very
interesting analysis that you could run
by saying okay well show me what the NBA
is saying on Twitter about a particular
subject and show me what they're saying
on Instagram Facebook or even in their
own website about a particular subject
and you can put those in one database
and we run analysis against that so it's
all those things are very very
interesting but to go back to the dag
the dag has an explicit execution order
that you set so it'll only do things in
the order that you set and if one part
of the process fails just like code then
that entire process will fail you can
put if statements around it to build
some workflow control but you have to do
that explicitly it's not going to do it
on its own so it's a very explicit type
language so some things we talked about
some parts of and you'll see this in the
next slide where it goes into the
overall layout of Apache airflow so
biggest thing is workflows code who in
here works in DevOps one two okay I saw
somebody shaking their head so dev ish
okay good enough being in data science
there's no DevOps for data science I
mean anybody who's ever done any kind of
analytic workload anything day it
doesn't have to be machine learning just
really any analytics it tends to be very
custom it tends to be very kind of
one-off where even though the report
that you're pulling is the same every
month it just seems like every month
you're relearning the entire process so
what this allows you to do is add a
little bit of DevOps flavor to it a big
thing that software engineering side has
been really that pushed to DevOps Purse
to infrastructure is code push to
continuous integration and deployment
right on the data science side that is
very that tooling is very much lacking
so this is a push to do that the
scheduler is exactly what it says it
allows you to schedule a workflow so
let's say you want to hit Twitter's API
at midnight every night or once you pull
that Twitter API you want to then store
it in your local s3 bucket at 3:00 a.m.
every night you can schedule those
things at a very specific time so it's
really really great for that the
executors execute your command
the metadata database is not a database
with the information the it stores the
state of your dag
so it's stores did your dag your graph
your instructions did they complete if
so at what stage they complete did they
go all the way through did one
particular thing failed at two things
fail what time they failed so it allows
you to get those error messages and then
go back and analyze the problem and say
okay what is happening what is causing
the failure versus with something like a
cron job you really don't know if it
works or if it doesn't you might come
back at you know three o'clock you know
the next day and then it worked and you
come back at three o'clock the day after
that and it doesn't and you won't know
till then defining tasks same thing you
have to be explicit in your instruction
set you have to tell it exactly what it
has to do so this is the basic
architecture of air flow if you look at
it arm on the start on the left hand
side the message queue can be it
currently uses celery which is I want to
say allows one task at a time but you
can use different executors you can plug
in different executors SQL alchemy
different things to be able to execute
multiple tasks or two different things
you have the scheduler which allows you
to execute your tasks you have your
metadata database which allows you to
store the state of each individual task
completion status the webserver is just
a really cool UI once again cron jobs
don't have a UI so it's hard to I'm a
very visual person so it's hard for me
to go into a cron job and kind of
diagnose what worked what didn't or even
just see all the different cron jobs I
have running at the same time so will
actually play with that as a local
server the code repository is where you
just store your code and the worker is
what actually does the work so the
bunkin the dag this is what a dag looks
like a dag doesn't have to be a one
linear thing or not one than your thing
but basically just one two three four it
could be
multiple things like you see here it
goes a B C D so you could set up where
once again workflow statements where
okay if this error comes back or if I
get this type of data or this amount or
this kind of call I want you to execute
this function if I get something else
that I want you to execute this function
so it allows you to build a more
comprehensive workflow and then be able
to visualize that and interact with it
in a more visual manner so you can see
that because like we talked about it is
directed and it is very task-oriented
you have to specifically tell it what to
do and in what order to do it that's
what makes it an a cyclical graph
alright so we're going to do some basic
hands-on nothing super fancy we're just
going to look at the web server or look
at some tags look at some example codes
and then tell your Apache airflow thing
I forgot to mention is actually written
in Python so if you know how to write
Python then you can actually interact
with Apache airflow it's not its own
specific language or code or anything
else it's all in Python I uses a
standard dot notation and everything
else will use a local MySQL database
where I have some Twitter data stored on
there not six gigs next time and then
you need a Twitter developer account
which is separate from your actual
Twitter account if you just go to
Twitter you type into the developer
account you get a API access key and you
have full access that's for a lot of the
Twitter BOTS you see that's how they
implement their boss they don't actually
point-and-click they just make calls to
and from the API and do actions and
different things so let's see if we can
[Music]
do some cool stuff
so first thing we'll look at so these
are some of our the example tags that we
have on there right this is just what
comes standard and they also give you a
lot of very standard dag executors so
you can build upon them there they're
really good it's just example code so
let's look at the basic hello world one
that I wrote up real quick can you see
that kind of all right so let's look at
a graph view so that's what
so this hello world task that I wrote I
wrote two things one was a dummy task
and then that fed into the hello world
task so you see that there's two defined
tasks let's look at the actual code
itself so this is what an airflow code
would look like I pass it some default
arguments I have my default dagger so
it's it's really simple it's basic
Python code so anybody who's ever worked
with Python can immediately start using
the system there's less you don't have
to learn a bunch of different ways to do
things and then this web server gives
you a lot of really cool functionality
you can have a chart show you Gantt
charts show you the percentage complete
of each task well there's no data here
but you can see the amount of tap it's
you can see the task duration so you can
track different metrics you can see okay
how long did this particular task take
to get accomplished you can also see a
tree view which is similar to a graph
view and just shows you this all the sub
directories all the different things
that task has to do let's see if we can
find our more complicated one
see this one all right so that's so if
you look at this this is what I talked
about in sense that you can write your
dag so that it follows a particularly
workflow based on a result it gets so it
doesn't have to be just one linear
operator that is this is the only thing
it can do it can do multiple things
based on the conditions that you set and
then also based on the state that was
returned to it from when the code was
executed so it's really powerful for
workflow development and if you look at
the code in here once again it's all
simple Python code you import the air
flow utilities you pass it some
arguments you build a dag function and
you from the from the web server you can
actually trigger it you can refresh it
you can do all the different things that
that you would do from the command line
so let's take a look at let's take a
look at
oh there we go can you see that can you
not see that what does it look like it's
small it's bigger better
okay so this is actually the
configuration file for airflow so if you
look at it here look look look
you can build very specifically what you
want you can actually set your
connections to different database stores
I'm just using a local database I made
sure it only pointed to my local
database let's see
so a lot of different functionality most
of it to be honest I don't really use
because what I don't use this that it
works so much we have because it's the
government we have a lot of internal
special tooling we use but a lot of
times when I do things on my own I tend
to use this kind of tool get out of here
and then let's I don't know let's take
some fun and look at some some Twitter
comments Python alright so this is a
table that I created to store some
tweets Twitter has it really a great API
and also like a great code like code
examples to connect to the database I
use twe P because TP is an open source
github repository that module that
allows you to connect to the Twitter API
by setting your username API key and
everything else so it makes connecting
very very easy so what we're going to do
is I made some turtle language and we're
gonna do language so I don't know let's
just see what language we have because
part of this thing is that Twitter
depending on on how stuff is going is
gives you different things so if the
language setting you can tell they don't
give you a language anymore so that's
one of the changes they made it used to
be you could have the individual you
could have the language used by that
individual user but that's no longer
feel they support so not happening there
let's see language
[Music]
user let's look at you know let's show
the tables again tables
all right let's look at some let's look
at some tweets tweet and then let's look
at user as well where let's see who has
let's see who has a lot of these Twitter
followers don't actually have a lot of
followers a lot of Twitter users don't
have a lot of followers surprisingly so
we want anybody who has more than let's
say 10 followers all right so we can
already tell one of the first things
where I'm gonna have to build in to our
dag is take out all of the non-english
characters there right so we can just
look at it and see first we have I don't
know let's look at this one Monty Python
we're officially 50 today so if somehow
Monty Python got caught up in my Twitter
pull for Python but that's kind of to be
expected so that you know that's
something that we're gonna have to
engineer out a lot of Monty I guess
whatever day I pulled this was the 50th
anniversary of Monty Python so just a
lot of a lot of Monty Python comments ok
and then somebody on here said Lisp
totally hate Lisp they don't like Lisp
night a lot of Monty Python comments
just a lot Monty Python I'm gonna have
to redo this query because it's just a
bunch of Monty Python and then we have
Spanish in there but we know from
there's a program oh here we go some
programming languages yeah
oh we have Chinese characters in there
there's a lot of a lot of different
things let's see if we can I don't know
make it less so let's see anybody maybe
who has 30 or more followers still a lot
yeah so it really ends up being a lot of
oh the incredible growth of Python for
us there's a Stack Overflow link that
they posted Oh Kerry announced to Shasta
software so it's a lot of different
things people are tweeting about they
had a Raspberry Pi a lot of Oh Raspberry
Pi my current temperature okay so this
is very interesting right here so we can
tell that this comment the hilltop TRG
was more than likely somebody set up a
Raspberry Pi to tweet out the current
temperature alright so yeah because it's
current temperature I guess whatever
location they're at so people using
Python Twitter for all kinds of
different things yeah interesting so I'm
going to open it up for questions
because I just want to do a very kind of
easy introduction into it show you some
of the things you could do talk about it
and hopefully somebody out there has
used it a little bit more than I have
because I've pretty much used it for
Twitter Instagram and some basic web
scraping to just gather a bunch of data
that I'm using for something else all
right
folks got some questions from out there
yes or some on the slide if you don't
mind please repeat them yeah sure can
airflow be used on secure non cloud
Network summer single PC is it a Python
package a separate application okay so
let's start with the last one first its
Python is it a Python package or a
separate application
it's a Python package so if you just do
was it pip install Apache - airflow
it'll install it it'll set up everything
for you and then the next one is gonna
be used from a single PC can it can it
be used from a non on a secured non
cloud network so from a single PC yes
because I'm using it from my single PC
can it be used from a secured non cloud
Network so because I deal with a lot of
secure environments are you talking
about something that is air gapped what
a computer is standalone by itself or is
it something that is just not connected
to the cloud okay
well I will say first off that I they
don't necessarily want us advertising
what tools we do and do not use for
obvious reasons but it can be used on a
secure network yes
the once again goes back to NIST and
what kind of data or database you're
accessing a lot of the database stuff
that I access revolves around marketing
and budgeting and also personnel data
not patient data but personal data about
our doctors and their reviews what
patients think about them or think about
our facilities so yeah it could be used
for that yeah that's it
I encourage you to just kind of play
around with it because the biggest thing
that I found while using it is that it's
very powerful but it's not at least in
my world not very wildly wildly used so
not a lot of developers know about it a
lot of people I know are still stuck
using cron jobs it's it's just nature of
the government we use the oldest
technology possible so we're not really
fully up to speed on it so I'm trying to
get my organization up to speed on it we
also work up a lot
very old databases so that's something
that I would like to explore if this
tool is well liked how does it so far
when it comes to AWS because I use AWS
and Azure for a lot of my own personal
work and also some stuff at work it
connects very well MySQL everything
connects great connectors there but I
don't know how it would do against more
unique type databases that people might
have out there in awhile that's not on
the cloud or maybe some database on Prem
I know so any other any other questions
about anything else
I'll bring the microphone jail so you
talked about scheduling jobs on air flow
do you know it but I saw that message
queue do you know if like you can send a
request to a server running air flow to
say like hey can like add something to
the queue and like ask it from the
outside world to do something or is it
only for internally scheduling work so
you mean
at-at is a task running already or is it
or is this something that like the task
is not running but you want to change
the task yeah like let's say airflow is
doing nothing and from like a different
application I want to tell air flow to
kick off a task is that yes yeah one
because it has a the web server and it
also has the command-line interface that
you can get access to the different
schedulers you can and because it's air
flow you can call it as a function
because it's your what you're doing
effectively is you're building a Python
function using some airflow api's and
some air flow packages so you could
implement it it doesn't have to reside
just an air flow it could be in any
piece of code that you're using yeah so
that's a good-ass that's actually really
a good use case I've I've done it once
but I probably should do it more often
because you can take it and put it
somewhere else you just have to make
sure the package and the module is is
there
[Music]